hallo meine lieben freunde ihr habt den
titel bereits gesehen und ja es ist
wirklich endlich passiert ich habe mich
selber bei ebay kleinanzeigen angemeldet
hat mir einen account dort erstellt und
haben über leute war
so witzig geworden hier zum beispiel hat
die liebe schuhe in größe 40 verkaufs
und ich habe daraufhin geschrieben wie
verlief die ehe mit dem brauch ich bin
sehr abergläubisch sorry die läuft noch
nicht haben nicht geheiratet wegen
corona also schon aber nur
standesamtlich und nicht in diesen
schuhen das ist ein schlechtes omen das
geht
[Gelächter]
es wird so viel besser jetzt schon so
lange hier hat jemand einen toaster
verkauft und ich habe daraufhin
geschrieben hat kann man da auch
kartoffeln darin garen hey muss man
ausprobieren wollen sie es haben können
sie das testen und ein videowänden nähe
in diese haben wollen dann kaufen sie
ist mir ab aber ich bin keiner der mist
umsetzen muss okay aber ich muss das
vorher wissen nicht mein problem kaufen
oder lassen
da schreibt man die kommentare ob ihr
eure kartoffeln auch in einem toaster
gashi hat der liebe eugen eine power
bänke
hallo eugen ausdauer
4000 leider nur die ok und das 2000 am
modell sorry ich kann nur mit geraden
zahlen die fünfte ist mir unangenehm ich
mal die auf die verpackung eine vier und
elf euro es auch um gerade mal 20 und
jeder ist ja das wäre so nett ja so
würde ich
hier hat jemand das kleine einmaleins
verkauft das ist irgendwie so ein buch
mit cd die hat allerdings gefehlt ich
habe daraus sind auf jeden fall
geschrieben hast du auch das große
einmaleins
das kleine kleine einmaleins das große
einmaleins habe ich nicht also kannst du
nur bis 10 rechnen spielend lernen
rechnen im zahlenraum bis 100 das
falls die unterhaltung der nächste
zeitverlauf tut mir einfach nur leid
es war wirklich nur ein job ich hab's
dann auch aufgelöst hat auch verstanden
aber
es hat auf jeden fall jemand
winterstiefel verkauft und ich habe
daraufhin gefragt hey hast du ein tragen
wird hat mit dieses bild geschickt
bringt die kleinen süßen hundewelpen und
hat natürlich den winterstiefeln drauf
und ich habe daraufhin geschrieben dank
gewickelt würde der hohen kosten aber
der hat sich dann auf jeden fall nun
bedankt und blablabla dann wenn ein
bisschen geschrieben und alles easy also
bitte jetzt nicht hier um äckern von
wegmann kraft nicht mal den hund ab es
ist ja hat jemand einen coolen
kapuzenpullover verkauft und ich habe
daraufhin gefragt kann meinen sohn im
pullover auch tragen werde er nicht so
gucken
wenn das ein macho hier hat jemand
stühle in einem italienisch eleganten
design verkauft und ich habe daraufhin
gefragt ich komme ursprünglich aus
portugal gar nicht die trotzdem haben
aber klar wer gerne brauchen sie auch
informationen zu den stühlen habe er
geantwortet
also wenn ich dann direkt gewusst hast
mich da jemand holen will hier wurde
eine körper vage aus glas verkauft und
ich habe daraufhin gefragt wie viel
gewicht verträgt die waage wenn sie aus
glas ist bis 200 kilogramm
okay das wird leider knapp vor ihr
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob ich das so witzig wenn
du weil ich das selber meint umgehen so
geschrieben habe aber
das führt zu weit hier hat jemand mutter
tochter herzen von pandora verkauft also
schmuck und ich habe daraufhin
geantwortet ich habe keine tochter kann
ich trotzdem haben
so stark gewesen wenn die da einfach
geantwortet nämlich verkaufsorder leute
mit meiner mutter tochter duo sprachen
lernen kommen wir nun allerdings zum
kompletten kracher weiter linken freunde
und zwar jemandem mac make-up verkauft
und ich bin ganz ehrlich ich habe diesen
typ der sich jetzt irgendwie mit
schminke ausgeht oder so ich kenne so
ein paar marken wie buglas oder ja mac
zum beispiel kajak oder diese galt die
attacke aber ich habe jetzt einfach mal
so gefragt als wäre dass irgendein
produkt von apple wegen mac deswegen
gefragt hast du da auch apple care drauf
sorry das ist apple care
[Musik]
ich muss mir einfach selbst auf die
schulter klopfen da hab ich so
ausgehandelt mitten in der nacht hat
jemand einen 4 gewinnspiel verkauft ich
habe daraufhin geschrieben hallo kann
man das zu dritt spielen
wir gewinnen sollten job sein nein
leider nur zu zweit okay ich hab nämlich
drei enkelinnen und brauche ein spiel
für drei kannst du was empfehlen nähe
leider nicht wie wäre es mit einem
kartenspiel das wäre eine möglichkeit
oder memory danke für deine hilfe bitte
um vier uhr nachts einfach
trotzdem süß wie hilfsbereite eigentlich
war egal man arbeite mit dem nächsten
ebay kleinanzeigen chat verlauf den ich
hier für euch vorbereitet habe meine
lieben freunde wurde dieses bild hier
verkauft und zwar einen keller fund ein
altes wandbild und die abholung darf nur
am
21.12 erfolgen ich habe daraufhin mir
gedacht ich frag mal kann ich das
[Musik]
da bin ich nicht mehr in bautzen mit
freundlichen grüßen oder sie holen es
morgen in der zeit von 6 bis 8 uhr früh
ab wenn sie es unbedingt möchte der hat
um 454 geschrieben als wenn ich dann
wach bin ne stunde später und das direkt
abholen fünf sekunden später
[Musik]
so lange in der arbeit weil ich so oft
keine rückmeldung bekommen habe aber das
ist der absolute burner
ja wort gibt mehr kann ihn nicht jeden
verkauft auf ebay und ich habe gefragt
warum will bleibt die
person geantwortet ich habe leider die
zeit nicht mehr für die beiden
verstehen haben
wir verkauft jemand den flipper
automaten von tommy und ich habe mir
dann gedacht mensch wenn jemand der
nicht tommy heißt weil der typ ist nicht
wieder das verkauft hat den flipper
automaten von tommy verkauft dann frage
ich doch einfach mal aber wäre tommy
nicht sauer wenn er mit klingt das so
seiten flipperautomat weg
[Musik]
es tut mir so unfassbar leid dieses
video besteht einfach nur aus mir wie
ich lache
ist so schrecklich bin so ein
schrecklicher mensch beim nächsten ebay
kleinanzeigen fail beziehungsweise sind
ja gar keine fans und ich zeige euch
meine verläufen die ich schon kenne und
ich mach mir trotzdem voller ab auf
jeden fall hat jemand ein ikea hemmnis
tages bett verkauft und ich habe
daraufhin einfach mal gefragt aber ich
will tagsüber gar nicht schlafen
wegen tages bett
es hört sich wirklich dumm an aber ich
bin einfach ein comedy gott kommen
allerdings ausschuss zum letzten ebay
kleinanzeigen feld für heute meine
lieben freunde und zwar ist es dieser
hier er verkauft jemand ein puzzle
clement tony und ich habe daraufhin
gefragt ist das schon mal fertig
gepuzzelt worden hallo ja meine enkelin
hatte schon gemacht okay gut ich hätte
das gerne schon fertig schon fertig
geputzt
und eingerahmt wer mich da jemand
veräppeln gepuzzelt und eingerahmt dann
wird's teuer kein problem für mich
11 ist einfach nur zum fremdschämen an
der stelle möglich das heutige video
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn euch in der heutige
video gefallen hat dann lassen einen
daumen hoch unter dem video abonniert
main kanal und klickt auf die glocke
wenn ihr bock habt dass ich irgendwie in
den nächsten tagen haben am zweiten teil
davon hoch lade ich habe auf jeden fall
noch ein paar chat verläufe plus würde
dann noch mal ein paar leuten schreib
ich bin gar videos produzieren für mein
österreich urlaub davon stories sehen
wollt dann folgt mir gern auf instagram
mich ist dann dahin sondern oder auch
auf die knapp 30 genauso wir können auch
meinem zweikanal vorbeischauen als ich
luke schuh also einfach bei youtube user
ein geben könnt euch da mal videos
angucken oder generell jetzt mal die
kommentare schreiben ob ihr bock darauf
habt dass ich einen zweiten teil von
mache wirklich selbst mit ebay
kleinanzeigen typen und frauen rum
schreibe jetzt
finden wir uns allerdings im auto könnte
jetzt jemanden kanal abonnieren und euro
an das video anschauen
ob das nicht auch mal ab